now
oxtail was something that we grew up
with yeah there's something you can do
in the morning and put it in the oven
because it has to be cooked really
really slow yes i'm gonna dust this in
flour it's amazing
how many chefs are using oxtail on their
menus today it's incredible it's very
popular it's very cheap as well
it's amazing i used to make it stretch
for like five or six dinners oh don't
exactly it's not that bad now i know why
we're all so skinny growing up
it wasn't that bad i'm joking come on
you know i'm joking but you see
sometimes we went to the butchers and
you had maybe extra two or three i used
to put in a saucepan and you had lovely
stock for
soup what was that spicy soup the really
nice
tony and i used to make the good pot of
scotch broth scotch broth i remember now
i'll peel a couple of cloves of garlic
i'll show you a quick word getting that
out get your knife and just
brush it
peel them and i'll crush them in the
garlic crusher okay all right all right
oxtail in
i'm gonna fry that off we can get that
nice and brown
and we've all braised it in red wine and
sort of chicken stock before but i'm
gonna get this done with a chinese
influence the chinese absolutely love
cooking oxtail
you started cooking at home quite early
on right 17 and a half 17 and a half
your mum died quite young very young 26
26 so who taught you how to cook
nobody taught you i think you just learn
as you get older
and you learn by your mistakes and did
you enjoy it i did enjoy it yeah
that was a nice vegetable the fennel
panel isn't it that lovely it's
beautiful yeah a lot of people don't use
it a lot of them use it in salads but no
one actually cooks it you just slice
that up them
now
these are nice and brown
and they look lovely put the color on
there
you just slice up the chili okay just
slice it down and keep the seeds in
there because i want some heat as well
yeah i wouldn't have thought i'd put
that in there no no one thing you never
used to do was work with many spices
there wasn't many chinese influences i
wasn't very adventurous with spices like
me no
i like ginger do you i love ginger
especially fresh yeah coriander seeds a
little handful
tim
yeah
some soy sauce
and quite generous in soy sauce four or
five tablespoons
that helps give it that saltiness and a
nice dark rich color on the vegetables
so as it raises the meat tenderizes
quicker
i would never drink fennel and
the chilis and
that
but it smells lovely does that smell
nice
and then a little bit of
this this is a
what's up
a rice wine vinegar is it yeah
what other tips would you give me in
order to save
money on cooking what got you through
that tough time
feeding
all six of us and
holding two jobs when that was in the
oven sea for about an hour and a half
then i would think right i'll make a
roast pudding i put an apple pie and for
the same sort of heat use the other
shelf in the oven so you weren't just
watching the pennies in terms of the
produce you're also cutting down the gas
bill
yeah wow
super nab
yes
yeah so oxtail back on top of the
vegetables gonna top that up is that
beef stock yeah this is uh
no a really nice chicken stock why are
you putting chicken stock in it because
it's quite a sort of light fragrant way
of cooking oxtail because oxtail itself
is quite rich yeah chicken stock's nice
and light
just cover it with stock lovely colorism
a beautiful color
little taste there we go big deep breath
okay then
well that's lovely i can taste the
fennel in that is that nice that's
lovely
oh jesus
damn water for nan
[Laughter]
take some watermelon no water is it
water come on
while mum recovers from the kick off the
chili to go with my oriental influenced
oxtail i'm going to knock up a quick
fresh radish salad
take a bunch of radishes and separate
off the edible leaves
once washed thoroughly place half the
radishes in the bowl with the leaves
chop the remaining radishes in half and
add them too
[Music]
next peel and finally slice a banana
shallot
add them to the radishes and season with
salt and pepper
dress with a good squeeze of fresh lemon
juice and a drizzle of olive oil
then mix
radish salad it's that simple
next up dessert delicious poached pears
i love pears ready so we're gonna poach
them with a little bit of chili
chili
i've never heard of that a little bit of
saffron no
no
no pan on
take off a little slice like that so
they stand up nicely and then peel
okay then and then the chilli you hold
that up and just go down yep
through
and open that up okay into the water
seeds in as well
a little bit of chili
water and sugar what are they holes
saffron is expensive but you only need
the tiniest little bit
a little pinch to make that water go
light and golden star in these how comes
the chinese you've like sliced it at the
end and it's not put in whole i want all
that flavor coming out of the chili
we're going to make
the most amazing star in east dust sorry
stars dust
should you get your star nice in there
seed
up and then
in
see all those little seeds yeah
and then
you start grinding
a little teaspoon of ginger give it a
nice mix thank you meg and that's going
to
dust the top of the pears once they're
cooked
right get your pears
drop them in there
[Music]
and that's what we're going to sprinkle
mmm
ginger and sternies
the rice is that
you're very good
that's lovely isn't it so once they're
cooked cool down sprinkle that over the
top right have you guys got homework yes
see you guys come back shortly thank you
turn that down and let them fall
okay bye thank you guys
after an eight minute simmer our pears
should be ready
now just get your knife on put the knife
through and see how easy the knife is
so that means they're soft and cooked
now you can leave them in that overnight
two or three days all right and they
just get darker
and more beautiful
the good thing about the cooking liquor
is that you don't throw that away
because you can use that again for
re-poaching
beautiful
i mean they look impressive they smell
delicious don't they
[Music]
look at the colors nice lovely isn't it
because they're amazing
and just
smells delicious
and then take your little
star and east dust and just
dust
over look at that nice lovely now for my
favorite part
the oxtail
wow
look at that
is beautiful
hmm
i'm just melts in your mouth doesn't it
i love the way you see that just
sliding down the bone there's no waste
in that at
would you all that to the table please
then yes
lovely and i will grab that
that is beautiful
[Music]
this is my ultimate thrifty dinner
sumptuous slow-cooked chinese braised
oxtail with a light and peppery radish
salad
followed by gorgeous chilli poached
pears with star and east dust
whatever you're cooking the secret to
making great food is to ensure you're
locking every last ounce of flavour in
that pan and this spicy sausage rice
does exactly that
[Music]
take these spicy sausages and pierce
that skin because i want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of this
casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas bread
onion less acidic than a big white
spanish onion and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because i want all that fat coming
out the sausages to sort of really help
flavor the onions onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to six minutes in the pan so you
can really start to caramelize them
mouth and my pepper
slice around
wasting nothing
i want to see that sort of
little core those pips in the center no
fine diced pepper the rice is going to
be cooking for 20 minutes so i want the
veg to sort of have texture after it's
cooked
peppers in a bit of garlic two nice
cloves
just slap down
off with the shell
in
now i want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well
in the center
in
now
start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the skin's off and the real flavor of
that spicy italian sausage is going to
come through
what's great about this recipe is that
you can use any type of sausage to get
the flavor and the heat you want i've
gone for the spicy italian but it's just
as good with mergers or cheerso
a teaspoon
paprika in give it that really nice
smoky flavor
rice in
and we're gonna sort of basically sear
the rice we call it in the kitchen
blasting the rice where we sort of saute
the rice for 30 seconds and it takes on
all that flavor
next white wine
so the wine sort of deglazes the pan and
washes all that flavor from the bottom
of the pan into the rice
stock in bring it up to the boil turn it
down and let it simmer
[Music]
double stop to rice turn that gas down
and let it simmer for 12 to 15 minutes
and just give it the occasional stir
keep an eye on it now get ready to
finish it
slice spring onions diced sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf parsley
spring onions in tomatoes in
off with the gas really important
otherwise everything becomes overcooked
flat leaf parsley in
but look
at the volume in that pan now that
is an amazing way to take spicy italian
sausages
to a completely different level
beautiful
[Music]
slow cooked fiery lamb
cooking's all about being bold and
adventurous and this dish is exciting
because it's slowly cooked and the
longer it cooks the more flavoursome it
becomes
marinating the lamb first
chilis we're gonna use a mixture of red
and green take off the tops
and just slice
in
garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just
get it in there
cooking
for up to three hours
everything sort of blends and almost
sort of
purees itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chilis
two teaspoons in a touch of dried
oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out is
extraordinary they release a little oil
as well and helps to tenderize the lamb
a touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil
just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb jump in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinade for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious
vegetables carrots and onions and that's
it sliced
secret slicing vegetables from braising
is not getting too thin you slice the
onions too thin they burn you've got
that horrible char taste on that slow
braised braising it's just a chef's term
that means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat incredibly moist
and beautifully tender so the secret of
braising is having a really nice thick
durable pan
get that nice and hot
just a touch of olive oil
in hold the bone because you're in
control then into the pan
i want that white fat to start rendering
so it'll add more fat therefore making
it a lot more flavoursome as it braises
chilies
cinnamon
in
mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're
getting the collar on the lamb which
washes off as it braises in the oven so
be generous with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of baileys
so now you lift the lamb up and get the
lamb
sat
on top of the vegetables
now just glaze the pan with red wine
this glazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
can really transform that dish
always delays
then bring to the boil and cook for
about 10 minutes to reduce
the wines reduce down by half now for
the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
a slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouthwateringly tender
now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and incredibly tender grab it by
the
the shank roll around that rich
delicious sauce
look at that
and get your sauce nice
beautiful
just get some mint
don't chop it
just pick that fresh mint and let it
snow
and there you go a very spicy delicious
melting in the mouth
lamb shank amazing
you